ああ少し岩尾の料理教室園ようこそ
今回の料理も私足腰というはをが務めさせていただきます
よろしくお願い致します皆様はアポロチョコというおかしいすきでしょうか
こちらにあるんですけどもまあ有名がおかしいですよねいちごの形になっている
チョコレート1つめ撮ってみましょうおおこんな感じですね親指の先よりもちょっと
小さいくらいのサイズになっていますね
[音楽]
違うわからーん
味がわから o
は彼らの味がまあはかなうこともないですはかなうことがないんですけども
小さい小さいですよめっちゃ美味しいのはわかるんですけどもあの僕身長が高いんで
やっぱ
僕に見合ったサイズのアポロチョコを作ったほうが美味しく食べれるんじゃないかなと
思いまして
チェーン席でちょっと味でよくわかんないで今日はね巨大なアポロチョコを作って
いこうと思いますとりあえずまず作るものとしてチョコが超必要
以下0てっちゃ準備しました約6坪のか
たちとして多分大事なのはこの15のピンクの部分なんでみんなが一応の地方が
あんまり売ってなくて結構取り寄せたんですけど
いちごチョコ2キロ分準備しましたあこのところの難しいところはまあ形なんですよね
あの特徴的なイチゴの形
なかなか素材があるだけで実現するのは難しいと思ったんですけれども私の仮説が
正しければ
beanie レーダーさがあれば作れる
と思うんですよ皆さんビニール傘知ってますかビールが去ってあれじゃん
ん
んんん
[音楽]
アポロチョコやビニールが山の幸半開きの増大とアポロチョコをなぜか誰ずしてるんで
この中にイチゴのチョコを溶かしたのここに入れてその上にサイロにちょこっと傘の
入れれば巨大なアポロチョコが作れるんじゃねーかというわけでございますよでは早速
作っていきましょうばいばーい
配球でまず必要なのが多分ねこのままでチョコを入れるとねアポロチョコではなくなる
んですよ
高
なっちゃってただ虚しい気持ちになるのでガムテープで止めます
たぶんこんなもんだと思いますねこれでも多分応募さでを持たれた分骨が折れそうなん
で何か保津をつけさせてあげましょうこういう日後とかに多分こうやっていればこれで
深さが折れることはないんでここにチョコをどんどん打ち込んでいきましょう
ここで問題があるんですけどそこのと化したかわかんないんですよねチョコって普通に
溶けるからタム超弱い熱を当てればた時ですよ
高
だからまずは苺の部分作っていきます根津後の部分だけでに来られますからね
世界が届きます
いいいいいい
ではつきます
超弱火でいいですよ多分なぜチョコだもチョコなんてもう手で握ってれて解けますから
ね
パッと桁人気てるいい感じいい感じまだ頑張ってみんな溶けてん
とっ
入ったこれ待った方がいいねまちまーすまたんだわー
おいフォアまず何が来ております
まっ
なんでなんでなんでなんでチョコレートは煙でないでしょ7日は誰だ
チョコレートは誰かがやばいなんか煙が出てる俺の知ってるチョコレートじゃないよ
溶けてるんだもあっあっあってますよ止まれますじゃない
大人編
チョコレートそんなことしないもんなんで思えません
焦げてんなボケてる超えてるややおかしいよマグマ山立って待って
[音楽]
ん
ちょっとまあ色々と罰がってはいると思うんですけど一応を受けました
大きい供給完璧に溶けてますね ok です完璧です対応しましたはい待て熱いに気を
付けて下さいはいあ
なんかすげー悪いことする気持ちになりますね
しゃらくせー
[音楽]
ん
いい感じじゃないからいい感じだねはい完全にはこの場ですはいもうちょっとですよ
ちょっと飛び散ってる部分がちょっともったいないんで拭きましょう
ああ
歩きずらいんでありますでは続いてチャンネルチョコレートの部分作っていきます
バッツたし熱い
[音楽]
あみすたぁ
ミスターねー
にさーいねえ
ミスターハイ的でチョコを入れ終わりました覚めて子供の外に持って行ってちょっと
待てば固まって最強にぜ回約5キロアポロチョコの完成でございますよ
完成を楽しみに
ん
me
海田ビル2時間がたちましたん
か違ってますビジネスを使って超でかいアポロンは作れるのかどうか
さっそく開けてみると思いますのでどう触ればいいんだでコア
とりあえず持ち上げてみますか
出たらいけるヘンデルいけるいけるイケてるまずいけたらご覧ください完全に中に
アポロチョコがありましたよね完全に見せたなぁ
骨抜くことを考えてなかった on のままだとミニで重ねちょっと詰まっただけ
ちょっと妻ただけや
どうやってこれはものでしょうかポイント a 待って
どうしよっかなちょっと傘として使ってみましょう
ます本当になぜこれを
思
[音楽]
plone 折れちゃったぁーどれだ思ってきても傘として使いません猫レミニール
だけ撮っちゃいますビニールさえ取れればいいんでしょう客に言うと
よしビール手に取りますもう
を待っていい感じでねこれ待ってます
待ってて
まってまって見えてる見えて見えてるん
見えてるよやっぱてっ
割れちゃったあでもで切れる出来てる普通のチロルチョコと比べてこんなにサイズ差が
ありますねこれも関西と言っても過言じゃありません
食べてみましょう
うまえんみんな
[音楽]
me
car